Joe was a guitar teacher at one point
and he taught Steve VI when Steve VI was
12 years old and he also taught Kirk
Hammet from Metallica right before
before Kirk was in Metallica you started
teaching him right yeah yeah he was in
Exodus uh when he started taking lessons
yeah would you get like pissed off like
well why the [__] did Metallica choose
this guy I'm his guitar teacher he they
should choose
me it was you know what I noticed even
though I was still maybe early mid 20s
at the time there was already a movement
with his age group that I could see that
was something new and fresh and they it
was thrash metal and they were at the
center of it and they were they were
creating it it was actually pretty
exciting to see young totally motivated
players uh come up with a new idea and
they were you know an sufficiently angry
at all the classic rock that had come
before them and they wanted to turn
everything upside down so you know was a
as a te teacher it was important just to
give them the information but not to
influence them in any way to let them
interpret it the way they want and
that's what Kirk did and you were proud
of Kirk right when he got into Metallica
I mean you must have been like wow
that's my student it must have been nuts
yeah no it was good because I have to
say among all the students we all felt
the same way like we were like we're
part of a team and when someone got a
good gig it was like someone scoring a
goal you know it's it's good for the
team so uh I think at least I felt that
way you know I I was proud of him
because I know how hard he worked he he
was tireless and totally
motivated